ciao aggiuntivo internet sua vita traver
oggi nuovo video che non mai fatto prima
a train i followers controllano il miur
shopping sapete che ho fatto altri video
i miei follower controllo la mia vita
per ventiquattro le speciali partite
della domenica
e siccome erano primark e della
decisione magneti ho pensato perché non
possiamo scegliere alla riduzione spend
e quindi ho fatto vari sondaggi e avete
sento in cui sia le magliette che altre
cose che cose anche un po strade e
quindi mi raccomando presente patatine
poco non mettetevi comodi vynils schermo
e godetevi il video se volete vedere
altri video del genere lasciato un bel
like e ad esibire live ne farò un altro
il primo ha suonato in assoluto il fatto
non è mai aprendo quella celeste con
quella carizza con la storia se mi
piaceva molto non solo perchè mi piace
celeste ma perché la scritta diceva
gimbel i packaging dell'inter
quindi era abbastanza motivante invece
quella scritta lomi states come sparkle
comunque 69 per senza di voi ha votato
quella che riccia quindi vale affatto
stupito vedere
sembrava più grigia ma è un tubo bianca
mi piace che abbia il colletto nero e no
pensavo anche le maniche ma non le
maniche no tolgo questa cosa così sulle
prime è sempre imbattibili infatti due
euro e cinquanta
allora se scritta non lo minutes
fitochimici space quindi da un mii
spazio comunque si è molto carina ho
preso una tagliata leggermente più
grande perché voglio che stia che non
sia troppo aderente sfrontato con questo
caldo preferisco che siano un po più
larghe e ovviamente tutte queste cose
sul mio instagram le vedrete indossate
farò delle foto con queste cose se non è
se avete già 3 inter adesso seguirmi
nome mi ha chiesto quale maglietta
preferito che quella rossa o quella
grigia con la rossa su scritto ben power
e in quella grigia the feature è dura e
il browser non mi ricordo comunque
eravate un po così così la percentuale
non era altissimo però la maggior parte
di voi ha scelto quella posta femme
tower ed il 62 per cento e ora ve la
faccio vedere
ecco mi piace la scritta oddio queste
questa rus a passerò è un pezzo anche da
un pezzo di adesivo che è rimasto
attaccato vabbè comunque devo ancora non
parlate perché è un po colorata ho
deciso divertirmi un po più colorata
perché in genere avuto pochissimi i
colori ma ho io riempirmi di colori
quest'anno quest'estate quindi mi piace
un sacco che quest'anno ha preso una
tagliata leggermente più grande della
mia fatemi sapere nei commenti se vi
piace quindi commenti mi farete fatta
neanche qual è la cosa che mi è piaciuta
di più di questo video pole in cui avete
controllato le con voi le cose che
compravo quindi questa è la maglia che
validate da un addetto questa maglia
rossa che non son dato che ho chiesto se
preferivate la maglia verde o la maglia
con le banane quello che mi piaceva
molto perché è molto semplice minima ed
iscritto b sii forte invece in altre con
le banane insomma in poche simpatica e
infatti che supera il mattino perché voi
scegliete sopra le cose più simpatico e
divertenti il 65 per senso di voi ha
scelto quella con le banane e in tv aver
scritto che anche voi avete comprato
quindi mi piace proprio
e tra l'altro lido primark mentre
facciamo la fila c'era notizia che aveva
piazza tagliente ha quindi sta andando
molto di moda per la moglie terry e cole
barare ve lo faccio vedere subito è una
cosa che io normalmente non avrei mai
scelto ma sono contenta che avete votato
sì così mi butto e provo anche cose
nuove
eccola qua per karina alle righe blu e
tante parole sia davanti che dietro vi
piace che molte le date da 1 a 10
nei commenti o sondaggio qui è una cosa
che harry potter
allora che chiesto allora innanzitutto
hanno messo nuove costiere potter da
primark akite con la testa di ron harry
potter hermione
insomma hanno altro colpo di cose anche
il fiume per scrivere le penne un po di
cose molto carine hanno aggiunto se non
siete contenti a quattro con poche cose
disney harry potter da primark sempre
felicissima comunque mi ha chiesto se è
preferivate che prendessi l'agenda
gruppo che che mi avete corretto e cibo
oppure quella della mappa del malandrino
allora in realtà il sondaggio è cambiato
dopo perché inizialmente la percentuale
maggiore era sulla mappa del malandrino
però dopo è diventato il gufo la
percentuale maggiore seconda 9 per cento
scusateci retta è il corretto oppure
sento un po del malandrino però quando
l'ho vista io serie 51 per cento mappa
del malandrino e caso devo avere co lo
screenshot di quello quindi nel me non
ha preso il buffo alla fine perché
ovviamente io cinque minuti che vota 5
10 minuti difese e poi vado a prendere
le cose veramente non può sospettare
troppo allora che le forze subito vedere
con questo diciamo questo perché è più
particolare a noi ancora the past e
avete di story potter
sapete di cosa si tratta la mappa del
malandrino
la frase giulio sono elementi non avere
buone intenzioni in inglese è guardato
come si apre allora 40 room si apre come
aiuto si apre questo no questo no ma si
possono infilare delle cose carpe il
problema si apre così un bellissimo e
poi dentro
nelle pagine si sono le varie impronte
come proprio nella mappa del malandrino
questo costava 5 euro è un prezzo ottimo
comunque fatto super bene ed è
originario di ridotte che ho chiesto
male che mi prenda questa maglia non
sapevo con quest'altro paragonarla
perché non ce n'erano molte della mia
taglia e questa era unica e la maglia di
miami di mickey mouse che sarebbe
topolino nel 70 non la presenza di voi
ha detto di sì per fortuna perché sapete
io quando vedo così disney i miei occhi
diventano a cuoricino e voglio sempre
prendere tutto allora ve lo faccio
subito vedere
da allora davanti alla scritta mickey
mouse e le date che è un po peloso se si
vede è un pò il rilievo e poi dietro a
pratolino cariplo è troppo bella e
ovviamente essendo superfan della disney
non potevano un prenderla e bellissima
non indossarla prossimo sondaggio allora
lo so che non è un ostruzione per che
costino felpa e ci sono tipo quasi 40
gradi sia caldissimo però ho visto
questa fetta di stitch e già non so
perché stanno vendendo le felpe adesso
dopo l'acquisto anche dei giubbotti
ma perché vabbè comunque ho visto questa
aperta di schizzi ma era troppo bella
celeste e non un po corta bellissimo e
bellissima allora gli ho chiesto la
prego 1 e il 91 per cento dei testi
quindi anche a voi è piaciuta tantissimo
ve lo faccio vedere da allora mi piace
tantissimo il colore e poi il fatto che
sia un po corta anche il cappuccio di e
nero la potrò dare adesso perché fa
caldissimo però in inverno la svizzera
allora il font mi piace un sacco come
scritto stizzo e così in corsivo e poi
c'è il piccolo stewie qua fatevi sotto
se vi piace che bottesi date da un'acqua
questo sondaggio è stato un caos perché
vi ho chiesto o trova in realtà fondata
da primark per cercare l'orologio di in
dono della bella e la bestia perché
hanno scritto che era arrivato ma sono
arrivata lì e non c'erano che
sicuramente hanno comprato tutti sapete
che io faccio la collezione ho visto
però queste tasse di rinnovamento un e
topolino e una mini allora io ho messo
su un dosso preferite con la media o
quella bianca e incredibile ragazze
ripsonde stato 50 e 50 per l'ipo 20
minuti o continuava ad aggiornare
cercare vediamo quali hanno votato ma
eravate concretamente di b fatto non
c'era una maggioranza incredibile voi
per un microsecondo c'è stata una
maggioranza del nero voi nuovamente il
bianco è risalito alla fine tipo la
sfera sono andata a ricontrollare 24 ore
ancora e dal 55 capisco perché siete
così divisi per queste due tazze vi dico
io quale preferisco io preferisco quella
nera di topolino
voi quale preferite fatemelo sapere nei
commenti comunque alla fine ma stiamo il
po di ore finalmente il 52 per cento ha
votato nero quindi leggermente di poco
ha vinto quella nera è in realtà sapete
i polli presule ho preso quella nera
proprio perché per un momento nel
sondaggio è andato un pochino che su
quello nero a profumo e che sono curioso
di vederla troppo cari praticamente sono
i pantaloni di topolino con i due
bottoncini sono i piedi e la manina da
cui potete prendere la pappa e dentro
c'è scritto mickey mouse deve sapere se
voi in realtà preferivate quello abbiamo
secondo me questa è bellissima allora
sono altre
perché magistati vedere in cui hanno
messo il mutato perché sono passato da
alle op
e ho preso queste due cose e non avevo
ancora fatto infondati allora la prima è
questo squish guardate quanto è carino e
uno squeeze il gattino già fatto che c'è
un grotto e poi su per cui sciolto ed è
una specie di non posso sembra così
schiuma da barba o panna a qualcosa di
bianco dentro
in realtà io sono super curiosa anche di
tagliarlo a vedere cosa c'è dentro
mi dispiace distruggere un iscrissi ma
mi rimane sempre la curiosità quindi se
volete che lo tagli si chiama gli altri
scurisce che le voci e magari nimis che
lo sai ma fatemelo sapere nei commenti
quella che carino quelle chieste da ga
stavolta d'impresa e questo natale un po
l'ho con voi in pratica potrebbe essere
una sorta di pallone che si può gonfiare
a è già quasi pieno la pratica si può
gonfiare e diventa una sorta di pallone
comincino ma io quello che voglio fare e
riempirlo di slime che fare una stress
ball abbastanza grande
4 e coraggio di vederla
fatevi sta bene con me chi poi
ultimissima cosa che sa bene che vi ho
chiesto nei sondaggi
[Musica]
volete che prenda questa variopinta per
fare lo slime ed 89 presenza di voi mi
ha detto di sì perché siete sempre
superiori se volete le più divertenti
allora nei controlli è un po inquietante
la cosa strana allora da passi stringer
e che funziona davvero bene guardate
prende una volta prendiamo squizzi
guardate lo prendete proprio bene quindi
0 prendete come lo strinse il spero che
però che funzionerà per fare lo slime
sta un po complicato ma c'è un'inchiesta
di per tempo e provare a fare un live
con questa ma devi sapere che come se
volete vedere dunque se avete dei
consigli su come fare il video è
incredibile non se la superbanca l'altro
la pelle di questa mano e cioè in cui
tanto perché sembra pelle vera
ma magari ecco qua si sentono semo le
ossa dentro fatto proprio bene magari
nel video in cui parolo tempo questa
vado a togliere tanto non pelle a pelle
tra virgolette gomma e vediamo come è
fatta la mano dentro
siete curiosi prendereste con questa
guardate che bella ma il pass allora
attore stefano fatemi sapere se ti è
piaciuto questo all incuria mente contro
l'altro voi lo shopping vorreste vedere
un altro
fatemelo sapere nei commenti lasciato un
bel live questo video è ora vi lascio
qua 4 caselline su cui potete cliccare
potete vedere i prossimi video shopping
altro volti dei divertenti video
challenge su cliccate su quello che
permette una visione